[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti per me è davvero un
onore e un piacere essere qui e potervi
raccontare quella che per me è stata
l'esperienza una delle esperienze più
formative e più d'impatto di tutta la
mia vita Io sono il capitano della
Guardia di Finanza Eduardo Anedda fino a
poche settimane fa Ero al comando della
sezione operativa Navale di Lampedusa
Lampedusa un posto paradisiaco chi non
c'è mai stato vi consiglio almeno una
volta di andarci in vacanza e io voglio
partire proprio da qui perché ho sempre
percepito durante la mia permanenza
durante i miei 3 anni e mezzo di
permanenza specialmente nei mesi estivi
un parallelismo quasi surreale
sull'isola da una parte nelle vie del
paese ristoranti bar aperti centinaia di
persone turisti che giustamente si
godono le meritate e tanto agognate
ferie dall'altra parte qualche molo del
porto di Lampedusa altrettante centinaia
di persone stavolta
migranti che sbarcano dopo essere state
soccorse dalle vedette in mezzo al mare
Ecco due realtà totalmente diverse
totalmente distanti che però convivono
nello stesso Lembo di terra e si
incontrano raramente di sfuggita quando
capita di vedere le vedette che
rientrano in porto con I migranti quando
capita di vedere il pullman che porta I
migranti verso il centro di accoglienza
piuttosto che verso la nave di linea che
poi cura il trasferimento in
Sicilia Ora facendo un passo indietro
probabilmente molti di voi non erano
nemmeno a conoscenza del fatto che la
Guardia di Finanza fosse dotata di unità
navali Ebbene sì Il corpo è dotato di
una componente aeronavale che in estrema
sintesi svolge il ruolo di polizia del
mare polizia del mare intesa come
polizia di frontiera in mare intesa come
attività di pattugliamenti nelle acque
di competenza Nazionale nonché
repressione di ogni traffico illecito
per petrato viamare chiaramente il
contesto lampedusano ha sempre come dire
indirizzato l'attività verso le
operazioni di soccorso e assistenza in
favore delle imbarcazione con con
migranti nonché alla repressione delle
annesse condotte criminali quindi volte
a individuare quei facilitatori quei
trafficanti che fondamentalmente
lucrano sulla pelle di queste persone
traendo un ingiusto profitto e
favorendone l'ingresso irregolare nel
territorio nazionale uno degli schemi
criminali utilizzato era il cosiddetto
fenomeno della nave madre quindi
un'imbarcazione Maggiore solitamente un
peschereccio con migranti stipati
nascosti all'interno che una volta
sopraggiunta nelle acque di competenza
Nazionale si fermava trasborda I
migranti su un'imbarcazione più piccola
e poi si dava la
fuga bene io in in questo scenario Ho
svolto il ruolo di comandante in quanto
tale ho avuto la gestione operativa di
tutte le unità navali del corpo alle
dipendenze con una squadra un team di
circa 70 finanzieri sotto la mia
responsabilità quante volte a tutti voi
Penso vi è capitato di leggere su
Facebook o piuttosto
eh leggendo i siti delle Agenzie
giornalistiche di leggere titoli del
tipo Lampedusa 500 migranti sbarcati
nella notte Lampedusa 1000 migranti
arrivati in meno di 24 ore e così via
Ecco dietro a questi numeri oltre a
delle persone c'è anche un lavoro enorme
fatto da tutta la macchina dei
soccorsi per la quale io in buona
sostanza nel rispetto delle mie
competenze e comunque anche sempre in
ottima Cooperazione con le altre
istituzioni interessate in primis la
guardia costiera era una sorta di primo
filtro ovvero colui che veniva a
conoscenza delle segnalazioni delle
imbarcazioni in
e poi
indirizzava dicendogli dove andare cosa
fare monitorare tutta l'attività
operativa fino al termine della missione
quindi vedendo anche il Trend degli
arrivi capite bene che in questi anni ho
dormito poco tant'è che qualcuno in
maniera simpatica e anche goliardica mi
aveva ribattezzato come L'uomo senza
sonno Però avrei mai potuto fare
altrimenti no signori No perché Fi
c'erano delle vite umane da salvare
fuori c'erano i miei uomini le mie donne
e soprattutto bisognava essere presenti
bisognava dare un
esempio Scusatemi
[Applauso]
seppur occupandomi della parte di
gestione e coordinamento di tutte queste
attività in mare ovviamente ho anche
partecipato a molteplici navigazioni
operative perché appunto altrimenti Che
razza di comandante sarei e quindi ho
potuto tastare davvero con mano in prima
persona cosa significhi stare in mare
cosa significhi andare alla cerca di
un'imbarcazione con migranti
individuarla affiancarsi
soccorrerla Comunque tutte
responsabilità che ha poco meno di 30
anni perché io sono arrivato a Lampedusa
all'età di 28 anni nel breve periodo mi
hanno fatto davvero capire il vero
valore del servizio del sacrificio
dell'essere un esempio
dell'essere un punto di
riferimento Inutile dirvi che la mia
esperienza lavorativa mi ha anche messo
davanti a scene tragiche scene
drammatiche ho visto morti ho visto
bambini ignari ho visto gruppi di
persone che davvero avevano affrontato
un viaggio della speranza e non non
voglio fare retorica mi limito a dire
che l'immigrazione è un tema davvero
molto complicato di portata Geopolitica
non indifferente una portata
internazionale ma soprattutto
caratterizzato da mille fature e
sfaccettature diverse che sicuramente
non non compete a me diciamo discutere
in questa sede
e scusatemi che sono davvero molto
emozionato e perdo un po' il filo del
[Applauso]
discorso diciamo è un passato troppo
recente
quello che volevo dire è che comunque a
prescindere io mi voglio concentrare su
chi opera in mare quindi su i militari
che quotidianamente svolgono il loro
servizio e lo svolgono comunque con
dedizione con professionalità con senso
del sacrificio voi dovete pensare che ci
sono giornate in cui un'imbarcazione in
un unico turno di servizio svolge 7-8
soccorsi continuativi dove ogni soccorso
significa circa 50 persone 50 uomini 50
donne 50 bambini 50 feriti disidratati e
chi più ne ha più ne metta ora vi faccio
vedere un paio di video che sintetizzano
bene Un po' quello che sto cercando di
dirvi e chiaramente dovete anche
immaginarvi gli scenari peggiori quindi
mare
mosso notte Notte senza luna quindi buio
pesto
quindi andiamo il video primo video per
favore S down
Please S down
[Musica]
down
[Applauso]
C
ST
[Musica]
[Applauso]
calma
Questo è il secondo
video
Oh vedete che c'è SP vicino
Eh stanno venendo verso di noi
eh andiamo indietro andiamo indietro
lasciamo spazio
allora possibilmente così a 1 a
un quan cazzo
sono
Ecco Credo che diciamo i video siano già
abbastanza esplicativi di loro però
questo è stato il mio pane quotidiano
e per tutta la mia permanenza a
Lampedusa ed è stato anche ciò che mi ha
pure spronato a cercare di fare il mio
lavoro al massimo delle mie possibilità
al massimo delle mie capacità Come del
resto anche il mio ruolo imponeva vi
sarebbero davvero una miriade di di
aneddoti di episodi da raccontare e ve
ne Cito uno che è quello di una
donna salvata ad esito di un'operazione
di soccorso che tra l'altro
un'operazione anche abbastanza
complicata perché c'era m mosso quindi
insomma particolarmente complessa da un
punto di vista tecnico che una volta
giun in porto quindi sbarcata questa
persona questa signora si gettava in
terra iniziava a baciare per terra e poi
scoppiava in un pianto a dirotto Ecco a
me questa scena Mi è sempre rimasta
molto
impressa perché intanto è successa poco
dopo il mio arrivo quindi è stata una
delle prime tante scene di Forte impatto
a cui ho assistito e poi
fondamentalmente mi è rimasta impressa
per due motivi perché ho percepito sia
la tragicità la drammaticità di quel
momento questa signora che comunque
scoppia in questo pianto liberatorio un
pianto che davvero esternava la paura le
sofferenze che quella persona aveva
sofferto e avuto durante il suo percorso
durante il suo viaggio dall'altra una
grande sensazione di sollievo perché
comunque quella persona ce l'aveva fatta
noi eravamo stati bravi avevamo salvato
tutti e quindi da quel momento la
missione è conclusa ci possiamo
concentrare sulla prossima segnalazione
sulle prossime vite da salvare sempre
con la stessa professionalità con lo con
la stessa meticolosità e con la stessa
attenzione Le cronache parlano chiaro
spesso non sempre vanno bene le
operazioni l'avete visto dai video I
migranti si agitano quando vedono i
soccorsi si crea molta confusione le
barche dove navigano non sono idonee a
portare tutte queste persone anzi spesso
imbarcano acqua anche in maniera molto
repentina e ciò può può portare appunto
alla all'affondamento al al
capovolgimento ribaltamenti e quindi poi
operare con persone in acqua oltre che
da un punto di vista tecnico c'è anche
della drammaticità della tragicità anche
per noi operatori però io non voglio
concentrarmi solo sulla sulle sugli
aspetti negativi di tutto di tutta
questa faccenda e vi voglio far vedere
un altro breve video che invece dimostra
quanta soddisfazione possa dare salvare
vite umane al netto delle competenze
specifiche di ognuno e quanto questo mi
abbia sempre riempito di orgoglio ok con
il terzo
video
Questa è stata Lampedusa per me e dato
che il tema di oggi è eredità Mi piace
pensare che anche io in un certo
senso abbia lasciato una piccola eredità
in quell'isola lontana in termini di
attaccamento di senso del dovere sia nei
confronti dei miei ragazzi della
sezione dei miei splendidi ragazzi sia
nei confronti di tutte le centinaia
migliaia di persone che dopo il loro
viaggio della speranza hanno trovato la
salvezza sulle nostre unità navali dove
Comunque davvero degli Eroi silenziosi
incuranti di tutto svolgono il loro
lavoro lavoro con assoluta dignità e
quindi voglio concludere il mio
intervento con leggendovi un post che mi
è stato condiviso da un comandante di
vedetta che ho avuto l'onore di avere
alle dipendenze a Lampedusa e che
davvero esprime al meglio le emozioni e
le sensazioni di chi opera per mare a
quelle
latitudini funziona più o meno così ti
danno una posizione numeri che per molti
non hanno senso per te è l'indirizzo
dell'inferno barca rovesciata gente in
acqua ordine imperativo vola il tempo di
uno sguardo i ragazzi sono pronti prima
di te loro la tua polizza vita tocchi
l'acqua solo con le eliche cerchi di
leggere il mare per ottimizzare i tempi
metti la prua là dove hai meno
Resistenza non vedi un cazzo La senti
solo la barca con il culo e con i piedi
È solo un prolungamento dei tuoi sensi
la tua spada di gemon 60 nodi un
ostacolo non letto è il confine tra la
vita e l'abisso mangiato dai pesci Ma tu
hai Padri di famiglia a bordo pensi a
loro prima di te è tutto così
tremendamente nelle tue mani pensi
veloce adrenalina al posto del caffè
manette a fondo scala hai paura cazzo se
hai paura un secondo una vita è un volo
radente l'angolo visivo si chiude il
radar è il tuo occhio nella notte
agganciati Poi vedi quello che un uomo
non dovrebbe mai vedere Sei appena
tornato da casa tuo nipote piang prima
di partire e ti ritrovi a sentire lo
stesso pianto in mezzo al mare nel buio
che più buio non si può La terra è
lontana è un posto in cui un bimbo non
dovrebbe stare È tutto così sbagliato
tutto così naturale se ti dice culo
guadagni terra prendendoli tutti
altrimenti ne porti dentro 99 Ma il tuo
unico pensiero corre al centesimo che
hai lasciato
lì a casa poi sotto la doccia Ti
tremeranno le ginocchia non dorm per
giorni ma lo saprai solo tu sarei per
sempre legato a quegli istanti che ti
daranno tormento negli anni ma sei lì
ancora e ancora ogni notte col mare che
ti entra nella pelle che ti gonfia gli
occhi che ti gonfia l'anima con i tuoi
quelli che ti sopportano perché sei una
gran testa di cazzo ma che senza non
metteresti nemmeno in moto che senza non
sapresti nemmeno mettere in moto Quelli
che si fidano di te e solo di te e ti
piace pensare lo stesso equipaggio il
mio Che bella parola equipaggio mi
riempie la bocca l'unica ricompensa a cu
aspiri poi è una birra ghiacciata sulla
soglia della veranda a casa sporco di
merda di piscio di lacrime sporco di
Gloria ma non te ne frega niente agli
uomini di mare tutto il resto interessa
poco che bona la birra ghiacciata Io
sono andato via ma ho lasciato qui i
miei fratelli la parte buona di questo
paese a fare il lavoro sporco che
nessuno di voi imm
siete nel mio cuore e lì vi terrò per
sempre apro un'altra birra stasera me la
merito
Grazie